this is footage from the Skies of
Donetsk a region of Ukraine illegally
annexed by Russia it shot from the
perspective of a ukrainian-controlled
drone you can see it engage in another
drone this one controlled by Russian
operators the Ukrainian drone Rams the
Russian drone and causes it to crash
this is the first ever documented drone
dogfight and it didn't take place
between military drones their DJI mavics
the same drone Casey neistat uses to
shoot his Vlogs small cheap drones like
these are already transforming the way
Wars are fought and as more countries
use them they will change the world but
the majority of them aren't made in
friendly places they're made in places
like China this creates huge National
Security risks for the US and its allies
but how did this happen how did the U.S
lose its lead in drones and what are we
gonna do about it
to understand how cheap drones are
changing War we need to look at how
they're being used in Ukraine in many
ways Ukraine is an attritional 20th
century style war tanks artillery
foxholes that kind of thing but
traditional tools are being augmented by
drones now it's hard to get precise
numbers but some experts say there are
as many as 6 000 commercial drones like
the mavic being used by both sides of
the war and that's in addition to
hundreds of military-grade drones early
on in the war the U.S sent Ukraine
hundreds of small military drones called
switchblades and they followed up with
deliveries of Puma drones and the
never-before-seen Phoenix ghost drones
are everywhere in Ukraine because they
can do so many things they can directly
attack enemy targets Scout enemy
locations help with targeting Ukrainian
artillery officers claim that drone
directed fire lets them take out a
Russian defensive position using just
nine rounds instead of 90. three
different drones perfectly demonstrate
how this technology is changing Warfare
the scary thing is that none of them are
made by the us or its allies
Iran is one of the world's leaders when
it comes to making cheap effective
drones and it took a totally different
path than other leaders like China the
US and Israel all those countries have
high-tech Aerospace sectors Iran doesn't
instead what it does have is a bunch of
regional enemies and crippling economic
sanctions so Iran's leaders needed a
home-grown technology that could defend
their country and destabilize their
adversaries enter drones Iran has been
developing their drone industry since
the early 1980s today it uses drones at
home and supplies them to allies like
Russia Venezuela Hezbollah and Lebanon
and the houthi rebels in Yemen experts
believe Russia is using about 1700
iranian-made unmanned aerial vehicles in
Ukraine the most significant of these is
the delta wing Shaheed 136. Russia is
using the Shaheed which in his branded
to the guaran 2 to repeatedly rain
destruction on Ukrainian troops weapon
stockpiles and critical civilian
infrastructure the Shaheed excels at
these bombing missions because it's not
a typical drone instead of carrying an
arsenal of guns and bombs it can drop on
targets the Shaheed itself is the weapon
once in range of its Target the Shaheed
hovers there waiting then when it
receives the order to attack the Shaheed
Dives straight down into the enemy
detonating the small Warhead lodged in
snows the Shaheed is a suicide drone
also known as a loitering munition it's
not meant to return to base but that's
okay the Shaheed is useful precisely
because it's Expendable they only cost
about twenty thousand dollars and at
that price you can get 50 shaheeds for
the cost of just one Russian cruise
missile or about 1600 for one predator
drone sure they can do things that the
Shaheed can't but being cheap and
Expendable offers some massive tactical
advantages in large enough numbers
shaheeds can easily overwhelm anti-air
defenses and successfully take down much
bigger Targets on October 10th 2022
Russia launched a huge barrage of
missiles and Shaheed strikes which
disabled about 40 percent of ukrainian's
power infrastructure Russia has also
used shaheeds to strike civilian Targets
in Kiev their distinctive buzzing sound
has struck Terror into the hearts of
millions of ukrainians despite being
destructive they're hard to detect they
have a range of about a thousand miles
and their initial approach path takes
them below the range of most radar
systems even if you can scramble a jet
or a missile to shoot down a Shaheed
chances are you won't be able to do it
for less than the cost of building and
deploying it in the first place all this
for about the price of a medium-sized
car
Ukraine has many new Heroes we've got
their leader zelenski the men and women
fighting bravely to defend their
Homeland and the American and Europeans
who have supplied Ukraine with shelter
Aid and weapons just to name a few this
hero is different though this is the
biraktar tb2 it's so popular that it
inspired a popular folk tune with the
lyric it makes ghosts out of Russian
Bandits there are reports of Ukrainian
parents naming their newborn babies by
raktar and I have a friend whose parents
even joined a crowdfunding effort to try
and help the Polish government buy some
of them and ship them to Ukraine so why
has this drone become so legendary
there's a simple answer it helped
Ukraine survive the early days of
Russia's Invasion Ukraine actually
ordered its first batch of biraktars
back in 2019 to fight against
russian-backed separatists in eastern
Ukraine and deter a full-scale Invasion
that plan may not have worked but the
drones did the viragtar tb2 isn't a
suicide drone it's an unmanned air
aerial vehicle with a 39-foot wingspan
it can fly for up to 27 hours at
altitudes of about 25 000 feet longer
and higher than any of the drones the
U.S has supplied to Ukraine while the
Shaheed has only a small Warhead the by
rakdar's laser-guided bombs are so
precise that they can be dropped into
enemy trenches and they're powerful
enough to destroy anti-aircraft systems
designed to shoot them down for months
the Russians had no answer by raktars
destroyed billions of dollars worth of
military hardware including a massive
warship in the Black Sea and despite the
development of countermeasures they
continue to be a thorn in Russia's Side
by raktars don't come cheap though they
cost at least five million dollars each
and that's excluding the mobile command
stations and comms equipment that come
with it but the thing that makes the
bairagtar so disruptive and so effective
isn't its list of specs it's the fact
that it works like a SmartPhone by car
the company that makes the byractor
ships software updates several times a
month that allow the biraktar to adapt
to enemy tactics and their Engineers are
constantly looking at other types of
drones for features they can borrow in
other words the company has a
development cycle that's agile and
responsive in a way the traditional
defense acquisition practices just
aren't they're constantly iterating so
their product can maintain a Competitive
Edge it's a concept that more and more
weapons manufacturers should be
emulating later in this video I'll tell
you about another company that's taken
the same approach but first there's a
catch and it's a big one by car is a
Turkish company not just that it has
close ties to the government of turkey's
president erdogan and when I say close
ties I mean that bicar's founder married
erdogan's youngest daughter in 2016.
he's since become an outspoken defender
of his father-in-law's government now
don't get me wrong turkey isn't a
hostile power in the same way that Iran
is turkey fought on the same side as the
Coalition that tried to oust Bashar
al-assad during Syria's Civil War but
erdogan likes to play Both Sides to
maximize his influence that's why he's
recently delayed Sweden's and finland's
acceptance into NATO the by raktar is a
hot commodity so it's at the heart of
erdogan's strategy to expand turkey's
geopolitical influence turkey is sold by
Rockstar tb2 drones to at least 13
countries including several that are
prohibited by sanctions from obtaining
Western uavs in 2020 biraktars helped
azerbaijan's dictatorial leader to
defeat Armenia in a short but very
intense War he even displayed footage of
the drone strikes on big digital
Billboards in the capital of Azerbaijan
now turkey's drone diplomacy isn't
necessarily bad for the west but the end
result is a more influential turkey and
a less stable World keep hold of that
idea because I'll come back to it soon
the biraktar TV2 can precisely destroy
targets and updated software the Shaheed
can be launched from a nondescript truck
bed and Destroy its Target before the
other side even notices but the world's
most dangerous drone is one you can pick
up at your local Best Buy this is the
DJI mavic it's a small quadcopter that
both Ukraine and Russia use for
reconnaissance and artillery spotting it
has a fairly low quality telephoto lens
and a higher quality wide-angle lens
it's stable rugged and reliable but
soldiers in Ukraine have discovered
another feature and this one thing makes
the mavic one of the most disruptive
weapons since the AK-47 Pop Quiz what do
you think was the biggest military
innovation of the early 20th century
planes machine guns artillery these are
all great guesses but I have a
suggestion that you probably didn't
think of what about the trench I know it
sounds ridiculous people don't make
YouTube videos about trenches and they
definitely don't think about them as
technology but they probably should
because trenches do something incredibly
important they protect infantry from
frontal ground-based attacks while still
allowing them to be resupplied it's
honestly not an exaggeration to say that
trenches and foxholes helped to change
the entire meta of war in favor of
Defending armies think about the
harrowing images of world war one where
soldiers barely older than boys ran
across No Man's Land only to be torn
apart by Machine Gun Fire or the D-Day
Landings where enemy fortifications
turned the beaches of Normandy into hell
on Earth those situations were so
horrifying because we know the odds were
stacked massively in favor of the
defending side now imagine if instead of
carrying rifles and praying they'd make
it across to the enemy attacking
soldiers could with the help of a simple
controller fly a small agile drone above
the enemy fire and drop grenades fitted
with impact fuses right on their heads
it would mean trenches and foxholes
suddenly stopped being safe and if they
stop being safe then suddenly the
soldiers in them vulnerable suddenly
it's harder to safely communicate with
them or to resupply them suddenly
trenches and foxholes begin to look kind
of obsolete that's what cheap drones
like mavic are achieving today in
Ukraine it's true the world's biggest
Powers don't fight Wars and trenches
anymore but most wars aren't fought
between superpowers they're fought
between developing countries or within
countries or between a government and a
group that's trying to remove it from
power but every fighting force can get
its hands on a DJI drone in a few
grenades this small seemingly
insignificant fact is changing the world
until a few years ago when you talked
about drones being used in war you are
probably talking about these
MQ-9 Reaper is the Pinnacle of military
UAV technology it's 36 feet long and has
a 70 foot wingspan
despite weighing up to 10 500 pounds it
can fly at close to 300 miles an hour
and it can carry two 500 pound
laser-guided bombs and up to four
Hellfire missiles the reaper is
basically a small fighter plane that's
controlled from the ground it also
represented a certain vision of what
uavs were Advanced military hardware
piloted from the ground that could be
made only by big defense contractors it
also represented the US's near Monopoly
on high-end drone technology but things
have changed for one the US is no longer
the only sheriff in town other countries
like Israel and China are now making
high-end military uavs and massive
improvements in commercial drone
technology have made different kinds of
drones possible and accessible drones
offer tactical flexibility that more
conventional technology doesn't cruise
missiles and manned planes might be more
powerful but they're way more expensive
while also being less versatile a cruise
missile can't help you find the enemy or
improve the accuracy of your artillery
and if a man plane goes down Behind
Enemy Lines you're missing a billion
dollar piece of hardware and a skilled
human pilot drone technology has become
democratized today more than 25
countries are either designing or
already making their own drones from
small surveillance drones to deadly
loitering Munitions and full-scale uavs
the list of countries buying them is
even longer but most countries aren't
buying military drones from friendly
countries they're buying shaheeds from
Iran by raktars from turkey or importing
djis from China so how did the United
States lose control of the market for
military drones well simply put they
just let it happen in 1987 the U.S
signed up to the missile technology
control regime this voluntary
multilateral agreement limits
proliferation of platforms that are
capable of delivering chemical
biological and nuclear weapons and by
itself that's a noble sentiment but when
your adversaries don't hold themselves
to the same standards it looks naive
reporting indicates that the United
States turned down requests from Jordan
Iraq and the United Arab Emirates to buy
U.S combat drones citing the agreement
and all three of those countries ended
up buying drones from China and although
the United States modified its
interpretation of the mtcr in 2020 to
expedite sales of uavs to its allies the
genie was already out of the bottle
today countries around the world are
rushing to get drones and as those
countries do their enemies will start to
feel nervous and strive to do the same
the whole thing begins to look like a
rapidly spinning flywheel or an arms
race a world where drones are everywhere
is a more unstable world but that's the
direction we're heading and a more
unstable world is great news for China
because it helps to achieve precisely
what it wants a new world order
DJI DJI DJI DJI DJI DJI is to commercial
drones what apple is to consumer
electronics it controls about two-thirds
of the World Market no other company has
done as much to turn drones from
something you occasionally saw on TV to
something you can have at home DJI is
fast Innovative and reliable it out
competes and underprices its competitors
this looks like an amazing story of a
startup that found a gap in the market
and created the technology to exploit it
DJI has a big secret it's actually a
Chinese military company documents
reviewed by The Washington Post show
that four major investment funds have
sizable stakes in DJI and one of them is
a Chinese state-owned fund that promotes
Partnerships between the Chinese
military and private companies it might
not sound like a Smoking Gun but it's
incontrovertible proof that DJI is
instrument of China's civil military
Fusion strategy now civil military
Fusion is all about blurring the lines
between the government and the private
sector it's how the Chinese government
modernizes its Army controls private
companies and maintains control of the
Technologies those companies create now
America believes that China's government
uses data gathered from DJI drones to
power AI models and enhance surveillance
efforts and the result of all this is
that the US government has said that
using DJI drones even for civilian
applications can directly contribute to
the Strategic objectives of the people's
Liberation Army in Xi Jinping DJI is a
major national security risk but despite
this the US Army was using their drones
until 2017 and in April it emerged that
the Australian Defense Force is still
using them thanks in part to insights
gained from DJI technology China has now
become the world leader in drone
technology over the past decade it has
sold almost 300 military drones to 17
countries looking at the list of
countries is like planning a very
unusual trip around the world Saudi
Arabia Myanmar Iraq Ethiopia Egypt
Pakistan and Serbia just to name a few
chinese-made combat drones are attacking
terrorist groups putting down rebellions
and in at least one theater attacking
civilians by comparison the U.S
delivered just 12 military drones over
the same time period and all of them
went to just two countries France and
the United Kingdom
[Music]
the combat uavs that China is selling
are highly Advanced and many of them
appear to be based on us-made designs
take a look at this side-by-side
comparison of the kai hong-4 and the
reaper but they've been upgraded to
offer greater performance and carry
bigger weapons payloads buyers aren't
only swayed by performance though
Chinese military uavs are much cheaper
than their us counterparts kaihong-4 is
estimated to cost between one and two
million dollars the reaper that'll set
you back about 16 million dollars that
suggests that China is learning fast
from DJI from industrial Espionage and
from watching its older uavs in the
field but it also suggests something is
seriously wrong with how the US is
making its combat drones for China
drones are more than just diplomacy
they're an increasingly important part
of the pla's military strategy the
Chinese see drones as a platform to wage
war at the highest level of conflict
this shows China's full confidence in
its world-class unmanned aerial vehicle
technology an increased interest in
drone and counter drone Warfare in pla
military ratings almost all military
analysts now believe that drones will be
a key feature of any confrontation over
Taiwan following missile strikes that
destroy taiwan's command and control
capabilities and offensive cyber
operations that weaken their space-based
systems the pla could launch swarms of
autonomous drones to knock out Taiwanese
air defenses and sink U.S warships that
come to taiwan's Aid the pla wouldn't
just deploy its own drones it would also
shoot down enemy drones at a Chinese Air
Show last November they debuted the
lw-30 laser defense system manufactured
by the China Aerospace Science and
Industry Corporation the vehicle mounted
system has supposedly solved one of the
biggest problems facing modern air
defense systems how to take down swarms
of slow low-flying drones
foreign
[Music]
even if Chinese State media is
exaggerating the capabilities of the
lw30 one thing is certain China is
determined to not let its Advantage slip
the same way the US did so here's where
things stand now drone technology is
rapidly maturing cheap drones like the
ones you can buy from your local
electronics store are providing their
value in places like Ukraine countries
are rushing to develop their own drones
or buy them off the shelf meanwhile the
United States lost the opportunity
created by its technological advantage
all because of a 35 year old export
control agreement as well as its slow
cumbersome defense acquisition processes
China has capitalized on all of this to
become the world leader in commercial
and combat drone Tech and now its
leaders are making drones a central part
of the country's military strategy this
does not sound great in fact it sounds
really dangerous but there's something
we can do something that means the US
and its allies can still access
world-class drone technology without
directly strengthening our main
geopolitical adversary and it involves
harnessing the most proven engine of
high quality technology ideas in human
history Silicon Valley
earlier when I was talking about the
Turkish company that makes the myractor
tb2 Drone I said that there was an
American company with the same drive for
Innovation the company I was talking
about is called anderol anderol is an
example of something you don't see very
often a Silicon Valley tech company that
isn't squeamish about working with the
military it makes three very different
types of drones let's look at them one
at a time the LTS is a small loitering
munition that can be launched from Air
land or sea like all of Andrews drones
the LTS uses lattice an ai-powered open
operating system that allows multiple
assets to work together and respond to
enemy threats in real time compared to
other similar models on the market the
Altius can fly further and loiter for
longer a single person can operate
multiple LTS drones at the same time
while its modular nose cone can carry a
wide range of payloads such as small
Warheads intelligence sensors and radar
jamming equipment the rise of cheap
swarming drones has created a big
problem for the world's biggest
militaries if you huge numbers of drones
can overwhelm conventional anti-air
defense systems how can you take them
down before they destroy something as
important as an aircraft carrier China
is attempting to solve this problem with
the lw30 system it unveiled at that air
show last year but what if the best way
to take down drones was just using more
drones
enter the Anvil Anvil seeks and destroys
enemy attack drones it uses laddens to
autonomously acquire a Target asks a
human operator for verification and then
smashes into that Target Anvil is part
of Andrew's end-to-end counter drone
system
the ghost is a versatile UAV which
excels at intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance its helicopter rotor
means it can take off and land
vertically while its long-range modular
payload in high capacity allow it to
perform a wide variety of mission
capabilities the ghost leverages lattice
to autonomously detect classify and
track objects of Interest including
enemy drones a single operator can
control teams of collaborating
autonomous ghosts which can cover about
a hundred miles of ground on a single
charge anderol's Founders understand
something very important software is
eating the battlefield and so in order
to be a successful defense company in
the 21st century you also need to be a
successful software company that's why
for anderol software is the master key
that unlocks every door there's been a
handful of areas we've really invested
in and I think we can move incredibly
fast and all of them have the same sort
of characteristics that's how do I take
advantage of you know modern
machine learning techniques modern
software networking to be able to make
these things wildly more effective than
they were historically we're not trying
to make like the world's most Exquisite
radar we're trying to make a cheap super
effective software-defined system
unfortunately not enough of the US
defense industry understands this
[Music]
sent a bunch of small drones to Ukraine
most including switchblade and Puma are
made by a company called aerovirment and
they make cool uavs but it's based in
Arlington Virginia the same place as
Boeing Raytheon and the Pentagon which
means that fundamentally it's still part
of the old defense establishment that
hasn't responded quickly enough to
rapidly shifting technological and
geopolitical changes established U.S
defense companies have become too big to
fail and that's a big problem because it
makes them less hungry less Innovative
and less capable of anticipating and
solving the challenges of the future
almost all of America's drones are made
in Arlington Virginia and it hasn't
helped us after being out innovated and
outmatched in drones it's time for our
defense industry to look less like
Arlington and more like Android now
anderol might face an uphill battle in
fact if success means single-handedly
turning the tide and re-establishing the
United States as the world leader in
commercial and combat drone technology
that might be too tall of an order but
that's okay because and General isn't
meant to be a savior it's a template for
a more modern more effective way to keep
us and our allies safe the United States
and its allies can't win the
geopolitical contests they're locked in
by acting more like China the only way
they can win is by harnessing the
creativity of our people and using the
free market to encourage the formation
of more Innovative defense companies
drones are changing the world Ukraine is
only the beginning the U.S had an
advantage but squandered it today our
consumers and even our allies are using
chinese-made drones that's threatening
our national security but Andrew is
approaching the problem from the right
perspective and in time we might look
back on it as the beginning of the
solution if you want to learn more about
how the U.S military has fallen behind
just watch this video next thanks a lot
[Music]